Russian President Vladimir Putin exited
the stage after his 14th annual Q&A with
media from all around the globe we've
got special coverage of the whole events
and reaction to it right here starting
right now
[Applause]
so Vladimir Putin spent almost four
hours answering an array of questions
from both Russian and foreign
journalists from the economy to pensions
to education to be the ruler of the
world even tongue-in-cheek of course the
Russian president was never caught off
guard following the QAR senior
correspondent more Gaz do not quite the
five hours that's his record but you
know pretty near four hours solid enough
but there was so much covered so much
from fuel prices to protests to even
nuclear war brexit mentioning those
France mentioned relations with various
countries the chance of conflict but one
thing that stood out towards the end was
an interesting question pitch to
Vladimir Putin about whether he wants to
rule the world and he does many Western
politicians experts and even ordinary
people see Russia as a threat they even
think that you want to rule the world of
course I do
I just want to know you really want this
what's the real aim of your foreign
policy concerning ruling the world we
know where the headquarters are located
of those who want to do this and it's
not in Moscow you can connect this to
defense spending the u.s. spends over
seven hundred billion dollars on or
Russia only forty six billion I mean do
you really think that our aim is to rule
the world this is just a cliche that's
being imposed by the West in order to
resolve their own domestic problems let
me Oh Putin also asked about Trump's
Trump's announcement rezident
declaration yesterday resident tweet I
supposed that he's going to pull out
American troops from Syria now that the
job has been done and Isis has been
destroyed that hasn't but Trump says it
has and Vladimir Putin was asked what he
thought about that intent concerning the
US withdrawal from Syria I don't really
know what that means for example the US
has been presence in Afghanistan for the
past 17 years and almost every year they
say that they are withdrawing their
truth so you understood them but they
are still there now
is the presence of American troops
needed in Syria I don't think so let's
not forget that that presence there is
illegitimate it was not agreed either
with the UN Security Council humanum and
no with the Syrian plans to withdraw
mass is the right decision Ukrainian
journalists also always welcome at this
press conference except in recent years
of the more nationalistic aliy minded
and anti zealously anti-putin ones seem
to favor displaying their colors for
everyone to see with the beard flags or
banners or indeed provocative questions
yes procedure did you know I just wanted
to ask you how much money do you spend
on gun bus people are starving there and
they've turned into slaves of Russia
frankly speaking just tell me this who
set the blockade between DOM bus and the
rest of Ukraine no it was done by the
Ukrainian authorities they have enforced
a full economic blockade of the
territory they consider their own they
shoot at those people whom they consider
their own citizens almost every day
civilians die though we provide
humanitarian support to those living
that but only not to let those people
start to death another important thing
that people have been talking about for
some years several years now
escalation growing tensions in the world
armament an arms race and Vladimir Putin
was asked about potential nuclear war he
said that would be catastrophic but the
risks is there because the global
security order the global security
mechanism is unraveling it is failing it
is being destroyed nations are pulling
out of arms treaties out of arms
limitation treaties developing new
weapons capable of defeating all
defences and therein is the problem that
balance is gone there is no mutually
assured destruction there is no parity
so everybody's trying to make new
weapons there's a global arms race and
it isn't going to end well
yes
the u.s. is now leaving the INF treaty
what's going to happen it's hard to
imagine what if the Rockets are located
in Europe what should we do of course we
will have to ensure our security with
some concrete steps let them not say
later that we are trying to get an
advantage we're not trying to get an
advantage merely to see your balance to
ensure our security so much more covered
that we don't have time to pack in now
almost four hours the record's audience
as well 1002 accredited journalists a
lot of questions times it was very
chaotic with journalists screaming and
shouting and jumping to be noticed and
to get their question across only one
Putin and many more journalists yeah
more odd part of our team covering there
also there are T's reporter among the
assembled journalist was really petrenko
talked us through his questions to the
president when you're sitting there when
you're trying to hold this little thing
actually the size of this was limited
this year for all the journalists and
when you're desperate to get this
question you can feel every minute of it
possibly even a second and when it gets
closer to the end it really it really
puts a lot of pressure on you but I was
lucky enough to get a chance to ask my
questions about ask my questions after
about one and a half hours while we were
there in that room you know if you get a
chance it is still not much because it's
only 30 seconds maybe a bit more than
that if you don't finish your question
within that time other people will start
screaming at you you know making noises
that that's really something that makes
it difficult to do the job but then in
these 30 seconds what you really try and
do is squeeze in some kind of stuff
about the most important event of the
year so I began with my question when I
met
in the script ball case and also the
killing of Saudi journalist Jamal
Mashhadi and the moment I did that
Vladimir Putin decided to draw the line
between these two immediately actually
would be kesaji was assassinated
everyone knows that there is evidence
scrip Pal is alive however there are
sanctions against Russia and complete
silence in the case of Saudi Arabia this
politicized Russia phobic approach is
just another reason to attack Russian
there if it was not script pol they
would have thought of something else
this is obvious to me and the aim is one
to halt Russia's growth at any cost
speaking of other double standards I
went on to talk about more things for
example the arrests of Russian
journalists in fact he is he used to be
the head of Russian news agency in
Ukraine and Karel Basinski and Ukraine
he's been arrested for months the arrest
of Maria booting in the US and the
recent detention of the Huawei financial
director in Canada by the way Donald
Trump refers to her as a bargaining chip
in the trade war game possibly even
openly doing that and I went on to a
squat American whether this is possible
in Russia to detain foreigners whether
we'll ever see that on under some dodgy
pretext to then possibly exchange the
prisoners that are under arrest in the
West and if we take the rules of the
game that are being set by America and
some other Western countries in this
case whether that is at all acceptable
the answer from the Russian president
was no he said that Russia will never
try to use this kind of tactic all right
all the questions aside every everybody
every year looks at the length of this
as well as Q and I as always a lengthy
event but it doesn't always mean it's
entirely serious when will you marry and
whom
these are two different questions are
you married yes so he is married and
wants me to suffer the same okay
let's assume I have answered the second
question but because I'm a decent man
I'll have to do it first of all to the
cameraman they said my flesh was
bothering them the flap was big but my
question is the small the Russian flag
cannot bother anymore I want to refer to
Kipling who said when everyone is then
the great game is finished great there
will be a meeting where everyone will
die this is a question about health I
think it should be the next one you will
not see me off our future lies in ideas
so we propose to create a Ministry of
ideas such a good idea
you